to the Android developer office hours we
are your Android EMEA developer
relations team I'm Sparky in Munich
Germany I'm also joined by Matt and rich
and Nick in London UK we're here to
answer any questions that you have
regarding any topics around Android
development
we won't answer any questions about
unannounced things but barring our
refusal to look into the future we're
here to talk about whatever interests
you regarding Android development so
let's see who's in the Hangout and
what's going on why we're Sparky
hey good to see you again we've changed
rooms this week as you may have noticed
I it's not just a faulty camera our
rooms turn blue we're in Moscow instead
of the standard Android room we don't
talk about future product is going to be
the future of Android so yeah hey you
know I'm good to see you there we goes
there it's actually your office now
I don't think you've called in the
office before no that's true this too is
the office I just bought my ticket for
the Droid Conn Holland so I'll be seeing
around November good good good good
looking for - yeah coming up already I'm
already on it
oh yeah that's already asleep there you
go you've got two of us heading out
already and I know that Nick is going to
throw it on UK are you going to run UK
you're speaking it then you care - yeah
so both of those guys beat Roy can you
can ask guys to be and maybe Nick is not
gonna sit behind he drops the joint con
season yeah good chance to get back in
see what the developers who else is on
the Hangout today rabu hey there Ravi
where you get where you have fun ready
can you have a mic friend today are you
just on chat right now yeah can you hear
me now yes yeah um
nice that thing yeah can you hear me now
yes yeah um I just have some questions
about audio handling audio in and so
I've been working on audio in Android so
um I've got a stream which have been
skimming through soundtrack I'm
streaming to the headphones aka so far
another audio track or maybe a sound
food which which sends the audio to a
speaker only which means that the
headphones signal will be uninterrupted
and and the sound pool which sends to
the speaker's would be an independent
one is there any way to do this yeah
different
I've been trying through using audio
track which sends a sound a continuous
sound through speakers or sorry
headphones and and I've been using sound
poun to use this as a as an audio
manager using an audio manager stream
ring
now you get it yeah we've had some
questions like this before
I think the first thing I would ask is
why do you want to do that I mean I
think that one of the most one of these
strongest use cases for her headphones
is that you don't play a sound out
through the speakers so I mean you know
it seems like you you have the
possibility of circumventing the basic
contract that the device makes that says
that when you plug in your headphones
you won't be annoying your neighbors but
the thing is here we are actually
sending the entire audio input signal as
in one source while the other one are
using as material notifications stuff
but still when we use a notification or
a ring instead of a stream it's
interrupting the string to wait until
this this audio is finished and then
it's it resumes the signal back again
and which is quite a bit not what we are
expecting I don't know if any of us are
really that that expert in the
multimedia framework I don't maybe I
won't speak for you guys online at night
I don't I mean technically I don't know
the answer I'm just not convinced that
it's a good idea maybe you guys in
London have a perspective on this no I
think we'd know about it if it was
possible because you'd end up setting
separate volume controls for the speaker
to the headphones and yeah when you
those events that happen when you plug
in headphones and unplug them for
example I like the music now we'll stop
playing so I know that you can get event
to tell you that events being a dinner
and then decide
my vision speakers probably confuse
users somewhat as well because they
would be expecting the speaker's to mute
it soon as they put headphones it could
be potentially embarrassing mmm listen
it's just not possible or if it is
possible maybe the way to do it is to do
it in the NDK I mean there's you know
once you once you get below the the Java
framework then then you can get much
more direct control over the actual
hardware devices you might be able to to
open you know electrical audio channels
that might just might not be possible to
populate at the NDK Aarthi at the
framework level sounds like a good
question to try on stackoverflow a multi
anticipation with stack overflow okay
great
if you want you can post in the chat
window are you the poster of the the the
questions in the in the moderator as
well um yeah okay
Andrew boy cool yeah I gave about the
same response in the moderator that I
just told you well I want to thank you
for coming into the Hangout and to and
to let us consider your question live
that's great that's what we're here for
mm-hmm thank you very much want to jump
in with a question
hi I I wrote a question down on the chat
bar but I wanted to know if I just
wanted to see if we're able to use
Google credentials yeah using I'm using
the account manager to get an ops token
and then I want to use Google
credentials in order to fetch data from
from I don't know from contacts or from
calendar and soul
yes there is a good way so you can and
for now
is there a workaround or something and
say besides the Google link in the chat
we okay you see that just mentioned
there's an example Google's API which
okay the Google Tasks will also be the
one the simple one that I can use and
switch to I don't know to get contacts
or get calendar events and so on yeah
you have to use different scopes okay if
you have any more live question to
people in it's gonna pretty full house
here yeah
so that looks like tall just joined us
but I don't see him Richard hey hey
that's the way feel free to either okay
if you can or type in the sidebar does
anyone want to ask a question while
Richard is typing or should we take one
from the moderator yeah let's jump in
with one from the moderator here's this
this should be a quick one Oren in
Israel wants to know is it possible to
show the in-app billing dialog you know
the Google Play in-app billing in
landscape mode instead of portrait I
suggested that he run one of those
utilities that forces the entire device
to landscape and see what happens and
that will probably work I think that
that when possible the Android team
tries to make its activities orientation
agnostic and support rotation and if
they don't support it by default on a
particular device is probably because
they weren't able to get a user
experience that they were happy with in
that orientation and so they locked it
out that's so my my guess there is that
if they don't support landscape on the
Galaxy Nexus because they weren't happy
with the UX that they got when they
tried it I thought it was already done
to be honest I've seen it appear in
landscape on multiple devices now
sitting on the Nexus 7 it appears in
landscape maybe there are some on a
smaller screen handsets that they still
haven't skipped I know it was there from
so but now there's nothing you can do to
force it the word versions of the
marquee client that would only show in
portrait mode which was annoying and
they are updating you know the ones that
we have here are showing in landscape
I'm just concerned maybe he's testing on
a smaller screen device said Galaxy
Nexus yeah I'm
I've never I'm never sure of what
everyone else is seeing on the Galaxy
Nexus because I'm usually running some
hairy dog food build that's you know
several several steps removed from what
any sane person would dare to load on
their only device we have a question
from Richard trying to implement the UP
button for the tablet version which has
to open lay out all the fragments and
the dual pane layout share an activity
and implement an interface well I mean
you know you don't want you don't need
the UP button if you're just changing
you know say say fragments on the same
activity or item the up affordances for
changing between activities generally
speaking when you have a dual pane
layout right you've got you've got a
selector in one in one fragment and your
detail on the other fragment and we
don't really do like we don't do back
history on that and we don't do
navigation history and then navigations
for changing activities what is that
about right Nick so I'm going to
interpret this question as you have
layers of hierarchy of navigation but
instead of having separate activities it
sounds that you just have one activity
and you just dynamically change the
content of that one activity depending
on which it sounds like you're trying to
almost you know you just on option item
selected so you can just kind of react
to them as that or if you use the latest
later version of the support library if
you were to go to activities you can
provide a metadata tag saying defining
the name of the parent activity so
they're all handled that up button
popping stack a free degree like
reproducing the parent so that work but
I'm not quite sure what the exact
I take taking what you said there and
running with a little bit if he's if he
is swapping off fragments rather than
changing the activity then you want no
parent activity and you just want to
receive that that menu event that option
menu event and handle it by changing off
the fragment instead of look at yeah
there are some some cases where the
buttons overloaded and doesn't just do
navigation so I think the good example
here is if the expand collapse pattern
which is probably best demonstrated by
Gmail way to really a message kind of in
in landscape and then go to portray the
message expands to take up the entire
width of the screen and hides the kind
of sidebar with the list of messages and
in that instance you might use the UP
button there to reexpansion of the
content so it's not always just kind of
hierarchical navigation so yeah is that
your question is it how do you lift your
app it's a which takes is the optional
item selected on the Android car ID
don't think it's in the action box right
and while we're on the topic in the
cases where you have that that slide in
that that slide and control panel on the
left side like in the YouTube app our
guidance there is to not implement that
if there's any parent activity right
that's only for top-level activities
with no parent yeah okay okay so well
two people typing we'll have a quick
look at the moderator there's a few
questions in the moderator from Marcus
that actually came through for our
session last week that then got answered
that the Mountain View low-level media
session so the top one was how to detect
if the audio codec was for AMR wideband
on a certain device they got to the
point where they could detect whether a
device for today am i but not whether it
was wideband or an Arab and so they
they've provided an answer for that one
and we're looking into what you can find
out I think the answer by
mentally when James done and but
interesting on this but interestingly
one thing I didn't see today in my
streams is Accra if I know only any of
you that they're using the Android crash
reporting system it's quite a handy
little six and lots of people using for
catching an uncaught exceptions and
sending off to Google spreadsheet we
there's a new thing that is coming
it's added which will actually on
jellybean devices also report back all
the codecs and the device your expenses
the pressure on supports so if you are
you know having this kind of media stuff
and you're using Accra then I would
encourage you to take a look at that so
you get a bit more debug information
about oh the device doesn't support it
or whatever all right John have a go the
next question in the moderator Sparky um
let's see what is the next question in
the moderator
ah the next one I see is one about SQL
okay okay so this oh wait no actually
they wanted to see before that is how
would a malicious android keyboard be
treated in the google play store
well if you know of a malicious keyboard
you should go into your Google Play
Store application and flag it as
inappropriate and then that'll be
escalated to the Google Play team when
the Google Play team finds applications
that are just misbehaving they are
suspended and in in extreme cases the
developer may be banned and as account
can be blocked so we yeah we don't we
don't treat lightly malware in the
application store no malware keyboards
can be potentially really really bad of
course I could read everything you're
typing asking Prince their permissions I
would totally agree with that if you
want to provide more detail on your
error approach instead of opening the
Google Play client on your handset and
reporting it's inappropriate if you go
to Google Play help on the web we have a
nice form that you can fill in there to
report inappropriate apps and you can
just Google for Google Play
inappropriate apps and
right away you can click on that and
fill in the details and it just gives
our team a little bit more to go on when
they're trying to figure out why you
think it's malicious okay anyone else in
the Hangout have any questions Before we
jump to the scariest yeah thank you
Venice for having a really scary it's me
same question here at sequel do you ask
your life then do you have a microphone
that bored of seeing us okay he's in a
lot of background well thank you for
muting then we appreciate that okay I am
creating an app where the user enters
some value daily and I start to see
qualit app should work offline but if
the user has multiple devices is data
should be synchronized instant not
necessarily what's the best way to do
this this says to me you want a Google
App Engine app up there and you should
be syncing data up there to your to your
App Engine oh I would do never idea it
might be to use Google Drive and a sync
adapter so you haven't sync adapter to
periodically and call it drive API to
see path somewhere so you don't want to
go down the route of having to maintain
your own you know storage service which
is what the App Engine side would be
doing you could ask the user to throw it
in their Google Drive folder or yeah
well if you're gonna go there then you
don't even need sequel do you I mean you
could you could write rows into a
spreadsheet or something can you can we
do that with the drive API yes cool
yeah in fact earlier on I think rich
even linked to early on about using
Google Drive from Android so does
exactly that
it has it takes the notepad application
which many of you might have used it
might work for that sample code there's
the first first time you talk support
databases and it takes that and every
time you save a note in so I'm not every
time but it has a sync adapter just what
you want to appear on it backs up that
database it goes inserts and updates and
to Google Google Drive back to a file so
you can have it on multiple devices all
in sync and logs you know checking md5
hashes to make sure you that's pretty
cool I've written a ever ever written a
Google Drive app that tied a a
spreadsheet to a web app but I've never
done it on Android before so maybe I
should try that next
yeah next my world is upside down I I'm
living and I'm living on the bleeding
edge here I just updated to two mountain
lion and all my scroll bars are
backwards that took me a good week to
get you see but it's worth persevering
with because now everyone else's scroll
bells backwards
yeah you know I I don't know how many
years I've been using scroll bars where
you are you mouse down to scroll up but
actually I kind of like it this way
because now because you know since I'm
using a trackpad instead of a mouse then
now my my laptop works exactly the same
as my tablets so okay that was a
question I'm a user but I have a problem
from an m.div AJ how from nowhere does
another location I get a system pop up
about a Google authentication failure
but the pop up only stays up for one
second and contains too much info to
discern where can I find the message to
look at longer is this why I can't
really ask you cuz you're not in the
Hangout we need a bit more information
on that before we can answer the
question its whether if you're
developing an application and you're
seeing this pop up then it should be up
until you approve it
so I don't know what you're doing to
overwrite the pop up and make it
disappear but as Sparky mentions in the
moderator I check your log cat and see
what's actually happening to to make
that pop-up disappear because our
authentication screen should should be
dialogues that come up for quite a long
time and let you accept or deny them
proof okay oops I mean Paul Hanson has a
question regarding NFC I'm missing the
ability to card emulate is her way to do
this the beam I mean there there are
some sort of a card emulation features
and there's an API for it it's in NFC
extras I I looked this up just earlier
today for somebody else maybe I can
maybe I can find that for you I don't
know exactly what it means I just know
that there's an API to turn it on I
guess it's it's needed for for some of
the e-commerce related applications yeah
I think we had very limited card
emulation okay okay so it looks like
that see the rest of the moderator
questions
I've already been dealt with in last
week unless you're on in there Sparky
that we have an answer that shouldn't be
no I think we've got a few actually let
me take a look at this
let's see keyboard SQL are you a codec
this is this one from Markus about
encoding was that also in the in the
detailed session last week because I
didn't were in there at the Mountain
View session as I answered it but I
didn't know all these ones from Markus
have they all been answered before I
think so they didn't mention quite a few
questions from Markus okay well I can
answer it anyway he says i how can i
encode media that is not from camera or
microphone or how can i decode something
without also outputting it search stack
overflows lots of there's lots of
examples where people have done this
that's means look at the new media codec
that is introduced in gaming yeah if you
want to encode it for jellybean onwards
look at media codecs that's awesome
although it's much better at moment
decoding that is in encoding also if you
want to do it over a wider variety of
formats and platforms ffmpeg is always a
good road to check out okay so does
anyone in the Hangout have anything else
to ask if you guys can stall for a
minute I will find that that note that I
sent about the the NFC API do you guys
recommend a good way the usage tests
that Android applications like selenium
any favorite testing automation testing
yeah there's a couple on there that
robolectric / rubato combination a lot
of people talk about the unit tests Yoho
how do you test your Android apps beyond
the spot currently currently not
excellent I am currently working on an
app which needs a Wi-Fi so and it's not
available in the emulator I know that
robotium can test on real devices as
well but at the time when I made the
decision so I'm more in the project now
or so well okay one suggestion at Google
i/o we had a tools partnering called
testdroid it's the product of contest
write this bar and they do a really nice
thing they have a system where they let
you record your entire test on the
device using key presses whatever
focuses and then recorded is the script
it uploads it to their cloud weather
then replay across any number of devices
what you like
have like a hundred varieties of Android
devices up there when they photograph
the screens for you they do all the
touch presence and everything automated
in their cloud so you can run you can
choose exactly which devices you want to
run it on you can just go and say I want
the Motorola Torre what I want Sony
Ericsson Xperia whatever Ark maybe and a
Galaxy Nexus a Nexus 7 and submit and it
just runs - runs them all for you and it
seems like a pretty cost-effective way
of being able to test your application
on a number of devices that are also
working on integrating that into
people's project build flows so that at
the end of each - you can sanity check
basically as you're doing a build and
run the tests so there are other video
if your Google for these services also
monkey run it's not about might be
monkey run a spirit test for you okay
and I think it was sound so we've just
opened up their own online testing that
pretty for developers in sign up to
Samsung developer Sony I'm doing an
online version so you can go to the OEM
developer sites as well right look says
that you can borrow devices from Sony
and sometimes a bit like device anywhere
where you can go online and yes rich do
to put the question back to you then how
do you test apps which which use like a
server server side back-end
do you and which might be intermittent
or so do you mock it out yeah yeah if it
was gonna be like a hybrid application
that needed testing was being built as a
contract work then yeah I would lock it
out as I was building the application so
I could run from the test and make sure
I was happy with the server side comment
and then test the service I can run it
separately in green or together yeah
yeah I can't say that I ever actually
went to those lengths because I was
building applications for myself I know
this is often the way with Android we
test on our users users are pretty eager
to give feedback on Android right like
disputing it it's kind of like um oh
yeah
apropos of testing on your users I will
give a piece of advice which is don't do
live user testing for your negative test
cases supposed to do that is success
okay did you find that thing's I
did I I just posted and it's I the the
file that implements the functions for
for card emulation you're turning on and
off card emulation is called NFC adapter
extras Java and I found it in the AOSP
just by googling on the file name so
that's what I suggested that Paul do I
don't I don't have like documentation
for what exactly those are how to use it
or anything I just you know somebody
asked can you do a card emulation then
the answer is evidently yes
alright looks like looks like your seats
gonna wake so where all the EOC is
anyone else have an issue they want to
bring up you know I just like to follow
up on my issue earlier hey hi there
there's two of you I jumped on another
machine I thought it might be easier if
I jumped on in person try to find a
quiet spot yeah so I've got an app I've
got the Silva seems to be working fine
for the sort of mobile version for the
tablet version I have sort of a search
list and then when somebody performs a
search they get a list of results that
slides in and then when they sort of
click on a result it then slides in a
detail screen and that will then allow
them to slide in a more detailed screen
again after that so I wanted to do
something like the Gmail app which then
allows you to sort of navigate back
upwards mmm so great so maybe the up the
little UP button would simply close the
rightmost tab essentially or eCourse the
right Musti tell you I apologize for
every chip we dropped out just as you're
saying about the fourth list that drops
in but that's fine so it just goes to
results list and then a summary detail
screen and then goes into a more
detailed screen and I'm just looking to
do something like the Gmail app where
you just hit the back button it would
take you from the very tail screen to
the details screen to the reserved
search results then up to the the search
screen all that structure all my for the
table layer all the fragments I sort of
contained within a search activity and
all the fragments implement an interface
there cause back to that
it's that will do all the fragment
transactions and swap out all the
screens appropriately now where I'm
having the the issue is is obviously for
the the initial top-level search screen
I don't want the UP button on that ice
cream I just want it in all the the sort
of child screens so because everything
shares the one activity is a what is the
best way of having specifying I want the
the UP button to be there for every
screen except for that top level screen
and then be how do I handle the user
pressing the UP button but those are the
two problems that I'm facing well you
can show and hide that that Chevron
right I mean that's that's a function
call a method it seems to me like what
you just want to do is is no you're sort
of know your depth of you and and
anytime your depth is greater than one
close the the rightmost fragment and
decrease your depth that's kind of I
mean sounds like a pat answer but that's
what I'm seeing when I hear you describe
it simply you have certain states which
you get into so maybe just you know
define as or there's consonants and you
know just hold your current state and
you know so you can say at home button
you know and you pass in your current
state and something like that but yeah I
think you're basically gonna have to
manage it so sure would be a good
implementation for that I'm trying to
think if you could get some good UX by
by using a u a viewpager there you know
rather than just popping fragments in
and out of existence
I don't know sort of mulling over you
might be able to if you had if they
weren't taking up the entire screen that
could be some really weird stuff that
you could do with it but not sure though
it makes sense
yeah I'd be interesting kid you don't
know if we change the width of elements
did a viewpager
yes or if you if you stick your
fragments in a linear layout can give
them layout weights no if it's in the
view you do with respect you have to use
a set page where check API on page oh
yeah that's the question yeah I think
essentially you're gonna have to handle
your own state so when you do like
during those callbacks you talk about so
when the fragment is talking to the
activity to do the fragment transactions
that's the point at which you want it
then I'll enable disable the up Chevron
yeah so I think I've got something to do
that I wasn't sure it was the best way
that the other problem I'm having is
about the handling the user pressing the
ease of a button as I found various ways
online but it just jumps the users trade
back to the home screen
yes I've implemented that method I'm
checking for that case well my slight
question is what what code should I be
putting in there because I found some
example code online and worked ok oh I
think I've got some slightly bad code
I've been using for the mobile stuff
which works fine but with the tablet
layout having the screen side-by-side I
found some code about using an intent
and and calling an intent but that
always jumps to use about I think they
made you probably want to be making your
own callbacks to do
right it seems to me like that that on
options menu options items selected is
where you want to look at your your
depth of detail and remove the fragment
and decrease your depth or your change
your state variable whatever that
happens to be yeah we're always thinking
I might have to do something customers
do my own fragment transactions I just
wondered if there was anything better a
better way of doing it in built well it
sounds like the answer is no there's
there's there's nothing particularly
wrong or hacky about using the fragment
manager to remove a fragment okay great
I guess you could I mean you could you
could allocate all of your fragments
statically and just show and hide them
you just stick them in the XML and just
if you know that there's exactly one of
each
you could you could hide it and then
when you need to see it you could
populate it with the right stuff and
show it I don't know it's another way to
do it I guess okay thank you okay I
suppose if you if you if you statically
create them all then you don't ever need
to actually search for one you can just
get the IDS of your fragments and and
just access them directly might be a
little bit simpler that way out or not
okay we've had another question dropped
into the moderator from my mouth so I
posted a stack overflow question and
then the moderator which is great and
the stack overflow question is one of my
activities embeds a video view and on
pausing and resuming it's calling on
pause along the stream respectively but
on resume is called before the activity
is actually visible to the user and it's
happening when he presses the power
button to lock the device then press the
power button again to to unlock it on
this human gets called before the user
unlocks the screen this is something
actually we've spoken about quite a bit
in terms of games games that play nice
was a target down and he ended there's
also a blog post on it
as a blog post they gave it was also in
their their Google i/o talk this year
you actually need to look for the on
resume and the on focus changed event to
say that you've gained focus again
because the lock screen before jellybean
was eventually an activity it was just
something which appeared on the very top
of the actual screen your application
became resumed but there was something
on top of it and it was only once the
user and unlocked it all got over that
screen that you've got the focus back
again for some slight complications in
just waiting on focus changed all on
resumed so you need to both of them but
it's in the blog post I'll post it on
the stack overflow to explain the exact
but you yeah it's a well-known issue and
from jellybean it doesn't exist anymore
so if you're tested on a new Galaxy
Nexus or Nexus 4 7 you see it doesn't
happen because the lockscreen has been
changed let's see we have another
question from Paul in the in the chat
here he wants to know can you use NFC to
bootstrap a Wi-Fi communication channel
maybe enjoy did we add that for
jellybean do you know what can you use
can use the what kind of life like
making you mean I mean I think it's
talking about using yeah using NFC beam
to to or using Android Beam to initiate
the transfer and then oh no that's not
why far that that hands over to
bluetooth for the bulk transfer this
there's there's a there's an emerging
standard for this isn't there is it's
like sort of a it's a recognized
practice and I just don't know if we've
implemented it yet I don't think we have
cool maybe a bit more specific about
what we mean by Wi-Fi communications I
know what are you trying I got this
image of someone scanning and an SD card
some way of using unity to write like
the actual okay we've just been drained
by a new viewer linden hello welcome to
the Hangout to discuss related to
Android development what are you working
out right now do you have any questions
just so cause provide a bit more
information in the sidebar
saying he's basically looking to
translate data and files using an acetic
miniature connection and then hand oh
it's beautiful Wi-Fi
well the good news is as on jellybean
that's exactly what Android Beam does
for you so you get that for free so it
will initiate a Bluetooth connection
between the two devices and send them
follow the booties it doesn't use any
form of Wi-Fi year I know Samsung have
it rolled their own solution there I
think it's be more something which
beforehand over what by Greg which is
good for them
but at the moment they're people under
I've got my way to do that so that's
jellybean on words if you were to bring
that back to older devices like I guess
gingerbread or my TS and I can you could
do that for you setting up an insecure
Bluetooth connection but yeah I don't
know if there's any part of that
Bluetooth connection that would need the
secure part of the system yeah but
you've got a serial connection without
the users I think it also needs to the
exchange at the NSC is mostly anything
stuff is all about pushing one way and
where's this opportunities to exchange
course NFC is just a great way to
transmit a shared secret because it
works over such a short range so why
it's ideal for bootstrap
something like a Wi-Fi or Bluetooth
connection did you paid you with
multiple pages on screen see Merton
refuse recent blog post cool in the
comments on a Google+ Hangout you have
to make news maybe yeah it's it's a good
idea it looks almost suggestively I've
seen I don't know what comment sent have
any new one coming from s from nowhere
it's a long way how do you make those
one by one shortcut widgets which linked
to other widgets like the one-by-one
settings also is there a high-level
summary of these somewhere I couldn't
find anything in the API go search that
so a one by one widget is just that you
just give it up nothing felt like an
icon one by one is the settings page you
can see those intent often if you close
your device if you plug your device into
your baby be long cat it's often when
you press settings will see the settings
intense firing you just need to fire the
same intent there all wrong listed yeah
and so also it's incentive documented as
well so you can build them very quickly
usually it's these one-by-one widgets
are about five lines of code it's nice
if you put different resolution icons in
there so people on different devices
having the mood you get the best one and
then touching them finding take like it
really Miley to other widgets like the
one saying oh do you think when you say
settings and then
says do you want Sussman's this
there's a little bit so we did seconds
yes we do that I think we do they do
yeah if you drop it yeah okay so let's
just say that's a configuration active
doing yeah okay doesn't mean the fall a
major feature of widgets but which is
when you picked it and you add it to the
home screen you can optionally then have
a configuration step so you supply this
configuration activity at which point
they can then kick you know what
actually you want to display on that
widget and said that's so you check out
the widget box for that configuration
yes well just in case they're not
actually watching and are there anyone I
won't so I do get one more question in
the moderator which said can you please
look at this issue in the in the issue
tracker which I'll go ahead and read he
says I override get child static
transformation to create my own
transformations according to location of
the child when drawing every child
worked fine before jellybean but it
fails when hardware acceleration is on
etc etc and yeah some some canvas
drawing operations are not supported and
hardware acceleration I don't know if
this is one of them but every every time
I recorded something like this to to the
guys in the engineering team implemented
it usually Roman G he says oh yeah that
has been supported in hardware
acceleration just turn off hardware
acceleration in used software rendering
so I would say in in cases like this if
software accelerator
if software rendering is acceptable then
then just you invite the bullet and use
that otherwise we can look into it and
see if it's a bug but it's probably not
a bug so it's probably intentionally not
hardware accelerated is my guess
hey al how's it going hey guys pretty
good I was trying to join using a mobile
device but was having no luck so I
thought I'd go back to the PC I could
hear you guys but I couldn't see any
video and couldn't broadcast audio
couldn't broadcast video but as you say
it's early days say wow I did get one
basically more than five second delay so
it was wanting to report a application
not responding so I put that through
hopefully yeah things will get better
oh you got any questions this week how
are you just hanging out I'm just
hanging out and I've been playing with
the multi-window stuff on the Samsung
Note so it's been doing a bit delving
into and it's written in a way that
potentially could appear in a future
version of Android if I guess all the
legal guys work it out and it's all
deemed acceptable so could be useful
that was a bit of technology yeah
basically splits the 10-inch screen in
two so when you've got it in landscape
mode you can have one app on the left
and one app on the right and they get
equal spacing but it's only for a
certain select few applications which
are part of the stock firmware the
reason behind that is there's a lot of
private api's that are used to firstly
detect whether it's present that's the
functionality to do two apps on screen
at once it's present and secondly
actually to implement the switch between
the dual screen mode and single screen
mode sorry Nick I lost you there mate I
just got so my concern like I said not
paper that I I've only seen this is all
based on the Burgess video yeah look
like one app was cut
someone and upwards kind of running so
that if you try to switch back and forth
they'll be like it
Jonah while it kind of might unpause the
application you find it and you went
back to it when it had it from what I
can see the juddered doesn't seem to be
noticeable it may be the only ones
active at any one time and certainly
when dialogues pop up they can be modal
dialogues you can't switch to the other
app and leave the modal dialogue on one
of them it takes control of the whole
screen it's it may be pausing it I would
suspect it is but it's nothing that's
sort of a severe judder on motor
switches I guess that's something that
they've sorted out recently because
there was one firmware update I've had
fritz so far they are using the Android
namespace yeah they've used Android SCC
Samsung Electric Corporation so they're
trying to tuck it away in their own
little area but the way it's written the
actual multi window window manager is
very similar to the window manager that
already exists in Android so my from
looking at the s3 firmer as well it
looks very much like they're using this
as a base part of all of their Ice Cream
Sandwich and jelly bean firmware and
this is why I think it's a potential for
being up streamed and putting into the
AOSP at some point because the way it's
written it wouldn't involve a lot of
changes for most applications to make
use of it new configuration changes it
does it does it switches to port rate
and it's it's just exactly the same as
you've got an orientation rotation you
know had those quite drastic changes in
the Sony P series is exactly the same
thing that's along with the two screens
and the clamshell design you've got a
button on the taskbar which allows you
to
makes apps on both screen or limit them
to one and even stuff like google music
was crashing originally so it's it's
their stuff to be wary or but I from
what I've seen of the the framework
stuff and looking at some of the way
they've implemented their it looks
almost the same as any app would get by
being put on a phone and twisted in
orientation so most apps most
well-written apps should be able to
handle it a lot easier than the kind of
huge change in dimensions that was
present when you were using things like
the p-series and the pad phone and stuff
like that I mean yeah I'll be
interesting to see how it goes I was
it's one of those things that I've been
working with some devices that you do
TVs and when you've got the space of a
TV having two apps on screen at once is
quite possible so it was interesting to
see whether it could be an Android
driven device and do those two things on
screen at once on the same sort of basis
at the same time it would be brilliant
at the moment all that happens is when
you select multi-screen you get the
drop-down list of like five or six apps
and you select which other one you want
to go in the pain so it's limited like
that but yeah that would be a really
cool the browser is actually the Android
stock browser with very small amount of
tweaks they I did a quick comparison of
some of the classes and that most of the
tweaks seems to be in the UI rather than
anything more fundamental and that's
literally because the way they've
implemented it they put in the action
bar the button to go between
multi-screen and single screen mode
rather making it part of the the strip
bar at the bottom whether most of the
buttons most the settings are go kids
decompiling framework jaws for fun and
profit to answer your question today but
I think we got through most of them
same time next week that if there's
anything special on this thank you all
for joining us today in Langer and
answering such answering asking good
questions thanks guys swing to